retour en france ce week-end en raison
du froid des récentes chutes de neige
une dizaine de stations de ski ont
ouvert leurs portes dans les alpes les
également dans les vosges ce reportage
dans une petite station familiale du
doubs littéralement aux anges car la
neige avait beaucoup manqué la saison
dernière maxime ne vous ai-je envie d'un
ça y est la neige est arrivée et avec
elle les skieurs ont ressorti leurs
spatules malgré le vent première
descente sur la poudreuse premier
planter de bâton et surtout premiers
plaisirs de la glisse et des sensations
retrouvées
regardez ce jour
là vers le bon vin on est le bon moment
pour moi
à retrouver les réflexes
pas forcément de 3,38 indiqué et là la
neige va bien ouais ça va être contente
de ça doit venir
un gang d'hommes sauf le lundi mardi
jeudi vendredi ou samedi matin parce que
j'ai ton nom
au domaine des fours quatre pistes et
est ouverte aujourd'hui dans cette
petite station familiale située à 1000
mètres d'altitude on se réjouit de cette
neige précoces
c'est bien de pouvoir démarrer
tranquillement et puis on s'aperçoit que
les gens ils sont demandeurs en première
année j'ai le mal ce matin il n'y a pas
tellement de monde mais ça va être ce
après midi et puis demain
la neige tombée ces derniers jours n'est
pas épaisse mais elle permet d'espérer
une belle saison après les mauvais
résultats de l'an dernier
on va espérer une meilleure année que
les processus parce que le février et
nous on fait à peu près la moitié du
chiffre d'affaires donc une très
mauvaise année et nous on y passait donc
c'est sûr que cette année là on espère
beaucoup mieux
demain les stations du ballon d'alsace
devrait ouvrir elle aussi de quoi
prévoir de belles descentes ces
prochains jours